I don't know if you can get a bigger
Icebreaker than something that happened
to me that I've never discussed with you
and I daring to do it right now
[Music]
if you've ever faked it
oh
well what might you would be referring
to
you know it
Drew I see you taking I said well I
think about it
I did it once just to see what it was
like I was I was like I guess maybe this
would just be a fun time to try what
that's all about and I'm like yeah it's
boring really did you really sell it
though
um I tried to I was like I wonder you
know I wanted to do my best When Harry
Met Sally impression yeah I totally I
don't want to do that by the way we all
know how to fake it but I was like I
want to see if it works and convinces
this person I guess it's also a good way
to just end it do you know what I was
actually trying to find
um and of course I'm doing a mad
scramble and I'm I'm definitely going to
unearth it and figure it out I do what
she's like proposing to me yeah thank
you do I was trying to find the nude
photographs you took of me on the set of
Charlie's in my dressing room I have
them
well I would love to borrow them so that
when you look gorgeous as you still do
you know when you're so natural and you
know playful and having a great time I
have a series of portraits of so many
people
did you take out clothes on guys I love
streaking I'm a fan too I was streaking
a few nights ago in La before our
Premiere oh were you in the hallways of
the hotel
[Applause]
okay we had a story in the news about
first dates oh sure um and how it's you
know according to this one woman she's
advocating for sex on that first date my
younger self says yay my older self says
nay you and Dave what was your first
date how do you feel about the concept
well I think I've told you that Dave and
I met at Mardi Gras together
you can deduce whether or not we had sex
on the first night
um
did you guys like do photography in a
field too what is that story because
that's my new favorite oh my God so I I
don't know what I was thinking at the
time it was just kind of like oh this
would be really groovy to do let's go
take topless photos in the cornfield
I cannot love it more oh my God
day three of knowing each other right
and the suggestion was made and I was
like okay sure
I don't know if you can get a bigger
Icebreaker than something that happened
to me that I've never discussed with you
and I daring to do it right now
so I was producing the film with Ben you
were directing so we went to Danny's
house to do story notes
I was at that phase in my life where I
was trying to make that list you know
that list of how many people have I been
with oh so oh that list in order
oh yeah so in order to figure it out I
wrote everybody's name down on a piece
of paper I then left that piece of paper
at your house
did you ever come across it
you know as a matter of fact the meaning
to talk to you about this
[Applause]
some of the names on that
no I I did make I made a copy of it and
I it's going to be in in my
autobiography no I I never came across
this so you never saw it no I never saw
it you're okay I wish I could save with
me okay good I felt it was because I
never heard anything yeah all right yeah
I I didn't no that's the irony too I'm
so embarrassed now because I'm like a
mom with two daughters oh yeah if you
looked at my list now it'd be a blank
piece oh yeah yeah you don't want to eat
it